decentralized artificial intelligence
that's the name of this talk it's really
combining two technologies that are very
hot today deep learning and blockchain
we know about these two technologies
right even if you're in data science you
study blockchain at some point there's
articles it's it's hard not to to look
at this space with some some level of
interest so we're gonna talk about how
to combine these two technologies
together to make something beautiful so
I want to start with a quote by a very
well-known public figure shall we say
the quote is he alone who owns the youth
gains the future and this is by Adolf
Hitler I just want you to think about
this quote for a second he alone who
owns the youth gains the future what did
he mean by that
clearly he knew what he was talking
about he was able to influence the youth
to kill people by the hundreds of
thousands so I want to ask you guys this
question who owns the youth single word
answers this is an open question you can
raise your hand once that you yeah
Facebook okay really smart guy any other
any other okay you guys know what's up
yeah exactly yeah Facebook snapchat
those aren't those are some possible
answers but let's let's talk about what
what the larger answer to this question
is who owns the youth who owns the
future so in the 80s the web was created
etc etc at the World Wide Web oh you
know we know that the web was created
but I remember going to CERN CERN it was
in Geneva I had a talk at CERN in Geneva
and it was amazing like that they
designs is there like we were getting so
technical they knew exactly what was
going on their questions were so
beautifully orchestrated they were
challenging me it was amazing
those people I mean the amount of data
that CERN has is amazing like anyway
that's a tangent when I was at CERN I
remember seeing Tim berners-lee's office
the creator of HTTP the hypertext
Transfer Protocol for the worldwide
but arguably without that protocol
everything that we're doing Karis told
everything about the web wouldn't exist
and I remember seeing his office and
just standing there for a second and
being like wow this is where it all
began and then I backed up for a second
I was just like oh my god and all these
kids started coming in those ago I
better back up and these kids started
coming in in mass and they were like I
don't know 8 to 8 or 10 years old it was
ike a school field trip and they came in
and they saw and then a teacher was like
but the guy was like and this is where
the worldwide was created and the kids
were like oh my god and they took a
snapchat and immediately left like they
didn't even like some of the kids just
when they one of them when the guide
said that they just kept walking
so that's who owns a future snapchat
right because I can't use snapchat so
those web 1.0 this man is web 2.0 widows
who this guy is - shout it out Jeff
Bezos who is the richest guy in the
world right now Jeff Bezos yeah in 98
this was Jeff Bezos he was selling books
that's all he wanted to do with
amazon.com he was selling books at a
very very small office his office was
just a desk right and now Amazon is more
powerful than Walmart its market cap is
higher than Walmart its market cap is
higher than any bookseller in the world
Barnes and Noble's etc all of these
global brands Amazon eats them up
literally quite literally Amazon
acquires it so Jeff Bezos Owens Amazon
he's the largest shareholder in Amazon
and Amazon is just one example
we've got snapchat we've got Google
we've got Facebook and these entities
that we've created over time have been a
result of entrepreneurs saying how do we
take web 1.0 and how do we capitalize
off of it how do we create something
where we can make money off of it which
is it makes sense right this is a
beautiful technology and the initial
eggs for the web were beautiful they
were very pure let's take this
decentralized internet that Tim
berners-lee helped create and let's
create services on top of it right so
let's let me take the server
and instead of having you know all these
computers talk to each other which is
very hard to do at the time let me just
make one central server let me make let
me use this HTTP protocol to create this
yet and set transfer protocol and store
all of that data on this central server
like that right and it made it easy to
do things like have an Amazon have an
eBay have a Marketplace have a social
network have a ride-sharing service all
this stuff that we use today is because
we were able to create these centralized
services it worked really well and there
were no problems in fact it was a faster
way to do things right it was a faster
way it was a more efficient way it just
worked but what's happened now is really
bad objectively speaking this is not my
opinion it is objectively a bad thing
and this is not just coming from me this
is coming from the creators of the web
Tim berners-lee Jerome Lanier the
pioneers of the Internet's don't like
what has happened today what the
Internet has become how do we fix this
[Music]
what does web 3.0 look like not web 1.0
or 2.0 not having centralized services
but decentralized services what the web
the original vision for the web was to
have decentralized services in a good
economy we monetize more and more but in
a bad economy we monetize less and less
what is the most valuable resource we
have today can anyone answer that
question what is the most valuable
resource that any person has today yes
another word for knowledge is data data
exactly but what are we doing with our
data right now we are giving it away for
free
in return for a free service right
that's that's part of the Terms of Use
for all of these services we use
Facebook Facebook's Terms of Service
snap test room service you let us use
your data we can learn from your data we
can profit off of your data we can sell
your data and in return we'll let you
use a service that's fine right it works
but what's happened is this is shrinking
the economy because all of that data is
being concentrated in these central
servers he's connected cores that
everybody has a connector right these
are gateways for the web
we need that data because this
automation technology gets better and
better as we learn to automate all of
these things the only agency the only
power you're gonna have in this new
world that we're very fast moving to is
your data but right now you're giving it
away for free
so what value do you bring to the world
when you don't own your data nothing
zero you have no value if you give away
your data you have no value so you need
to own your data and profit from your
data right this is akin to something
like a basic income when robotics and
automation technology and AI and deep
learning and machine learning when all
of that gets good enough in the next
five to ten years probably everything
will be automated everything everything
that can be automated will be automated
I just made that up on the spot you call
it Milo there's accountability as well
okay so accountability is we don't know
what they're doing with our data right
first of all we want to own our data we
want to profit off of our data right now
we're giving it away for free and
they're doing something with it that we
don't even know what it is they don't
have to tell us right they don't tell us
what they're doing with my data they
could give it away to governments they
could use to spy on people I was having
a conversation with a friend a few days
ago okay we were talking about something
a single topic later on on her phone in
the bag it said the topic that we were
talking about they are listening on our
phones they are listening in real-time
Facebook is listening our phones they
are listening to us they are using that
data because there are no checks and
balances that's just what's happened
they're so powerful they're all around
us the Internet of Things is really a
set of spy devices for these central
authorities and lastly we are trying to
solve AI and I'm going to talk about
that at the very very end but we're
trying to solve AI and we need a way to
do that and this is how we do that all
of these problems a shrinking economy
data ownership accountability and
towards general intelligence all of that
can be solved if we move to web 3.0 so
you guys wouldn't with me like we need
to move to web 3.0 right this is that
this is the plan how do we do this so
I'm gonna tell you how to do this okay
I'm gonna tell you how to do this I'm
gonna show you right now how to do this
you ready okay there we go it
all starts with something very very
simple the link fullest well here it's
same a linked list before yeah okay so
the linked list is a very very simple
data structure I've got the code for it
right here don't worry never code it
before don't worry about it it's only
you know twelve lines of code twelve
single lines in Python and what this
does is it creates a data structure
called a linked list and a linked list
is just a very simple object that's
linked to the next object that's linked
to the next object that's linked to the
next object and just goes on as but as
much as you want and we can make one in
Python we'll just say class node this is
a class this thing - Square and let's
say let's give it some functions get
data okay that's going to give us what's
inside of york which is if we could
store it the word hello' get next get
the next node in the list stack send
data what do I want to put in this thing
hello a number an image a video whatever
data and set next what's going to be
that the data in the next linked the
next node in the linked list that's it
there's a simple data structure this is
going to help us move towards web 3.0
you might be thinking wait a second no
this has been around since the 80s
how is it going to help init with
anything so let's take this linked list
let's let's take this linked list and
let's store a copy of it on let's say a
million computers let's just say hey
guys I've got this linked list I want
you to store a copy of it and inside of
this linked list we're not gonna store
the word hello that does nothing for us
let's instead store a transaction and
not just one transaction several
transactions in fact millions of
transactions between people payments
let's store that and let's try to make
it so that no one can modify this linked
list no one can change this transactions
in this linked list how do we do that
okay what if we had a separate system of
people and all they did was they solved
random mathematical problems with our
computer
and this required a lot of computing
power like a lot so much so that in
order for you to be able to change any
of the data in any of these nodes you
would have to have more than 50% of the
computing power of all of those nodes
that are solving these random
mathematical problems now what if the
amount of computing power in those nodes
was greater than the 500 fastest
supercomputers in the world combined
well then you would have to have more
computing power and the 500 fastest
supercomputers in the world combined
to change this the data in this linked
list
what that means is no one could change
the data in this linked list so if we
did that we had a linked list that
everybody stored a copy of that no one
could change the data and we would call
it a blockchain and that's what the
Bitcoin blockchain is it's a glorified
linked list that's it it's a glorified
linked list and instead of calling them
links or nodes we call them blocks and
the reason it's called a chain is
because it's not just pointing to a
random node with the word hello in it
it's pointing to a random node with
transactions in it and the reason that
the transactions are stored as this tree
decision tree to be specific we can call
it a merkel tag as well but not to talk
about that is because that's just a more
efficient way of storing it and
retrieving from it but you can just
think of it at an abstract level as just
a list of transactions and that's a
blockchain so this is a very new idea
right this is this was you know eight
nine ten years ago when Satoshi invented
this this this concept it was the first
time where we could say I'm gonna store
my transactions in this data structure
that's what the function is it's a data
structure
I'm gonna store my data in this thing
and no one's gonna be able to modify
those transactions that's why we use
banks right there are only a few real
banks in the world that we trust enough
to store our money in or you know
something very valuable as we trust that
they're not going to modify essentially
the the list of transactions in our
account
they're not gonna modify that there's a
this is the amount you had before and
this is the amount you have now trust us
right and that's it we trust them
but what if we could store our money in
a way that we didn't have to trust the
bank so there's not a third party this
is the first time that we never been
able to do that in the advent of this
data structure right that's cool okay
okay we don't need a bank great so what
what else could we store in this thing
besides transactions we don't need to
trust a third party to store our
transactions we don't need to trust a
third party to store our data we don't
need to trust trust a third party to
store our code what about our web apps
what about our apps like snapchat and
Facebook and Google what if we could
store code in this state not just
transactions and that is what etherium
is blockchain is they took bitcoins
blockchain they added a bunch of other
data like logs dificulty timestamps
mixes but really what matters is this
the code you don't just store
transactions in the ethereum blockchain
you store code what that means is every
computer every node remember its
glorified linked list every node in the
network is storing code instead of
pushing code to a single server like
Heroku right that's how we usually build
web apps we store it on a single node
that everybody has to agree upon so in
order to modify that code you would have
to have more computing power than the
500 fastest supercomputers in the world
combined so this is a trustless way to
build web apps and that's how we're
gonna get to web 3.0 so what does code
on aetherium look like
go back this this 17 line of code
snippet is what you would call an
initial coin offering 17 lines of code
is responsible for raising more money in
the past two years that have been raised
by every IPO in the past ten we're
talking about more than a hundred
billion US dollars worth of investments
from the public the public every IC
o---- that you're seeing these days is a
result of this someone takes this as a
variable that says how many you know
shares or coins or tokens do I want and
how much do I want to sell those tokens
for they take this code and they push it
to the etherium blockchain via a push
command in terminal or they can do if
you're a feel web app and then they have
this public address you know 25
characters or poor more and they say
here's the address
ICO time invest and then people just you
know 30 million in a single day this
kind of stuff happens this is very
powerful and no one controls this right
this is the advent of a new structure
similar to a corporation a new type of
institution that no one no one controls
and we can do this with a theory of
blockchain because we don't have to
trust a third party not just a bank but
even a government legal documents things
like that we can build these with smart
contracts thanks every every time we've
had to require to trust a third party we
can remove that and push that instead in
the form of contracts to the etherium
blockchain there's a problem though so
if you think about okay well I'm gonna
make a web app and it's gonna it's going
to pull from the weather comm API and
it's just going to tell you the weather
that's it okay so it's called my weather
app decentralized comm and all it
displays is a single text the weather
today in Singapore and it pulls that
data from weather calms API with the
parameter of Singapore now it returns
the result and it displays that write
whatever degrees Celsius if we were to
do that on the ethereum blockchain it
wouldn't work why because every single
node in the network has to pull back
data at the same time right because
they're all executing that code at the
same time but but the weather changes
over time right so they would all have
to agree upon the time how do you do
that
you can't right so the solution to this
is to have what's called an Oracle and
the Oracle is a trusted third-party
source that speaks to the web that the
etherium blockchain can pull from so you
might be thinking wait a second okay I
thought this was trustless what it was
is deal with this Oracle thing there are
networks of Oracle's out there you know
delegations four or five of them and
they can all agree a crook agree on
things they can have consensus on some
data but this is a solution to pulling
data from the from the web 2.0 in the
form of api's until we have a better
solution but that's how it works right
now so you might be thinking okay we can
have our application level constructs on
the etherion blockchain we can pull data
in the form of Oracle's from the web but
then how do we store like huge databases
onto the blockchain could we do that I
mean you could technically but then
every miner everyone who's downloading a
copy of this blockchain would then have
to store all of that data on their
personal computer Facebook has a lot of
data if we were to decentralized
Facebook and say this is the ethereum
version of Facebook everybody would have
to store a copy of Facebook that's just
infeasible so what we need is not just a
an application level construct that says
here are user names your your tweets
here you know etc we need it to point to
some kind of decentralized data store a
storage for data that is not owned by
anyone now the best solution for this
that I found is called the
interplanetary file system so high PFS
is big there's there's a lot to go into
about ipfs it's a beautiful system the
way it works but essentially it's a
group of computers that all agree on
some data so if I want to push some data
to Google Cloud or AWS right now right
these services own that data right so I
would say you know got some huge video
let me push it to Google Cloud or AWS
and they would store it
how do we decentralize that with ipfs
it's a network of computers who are
saying I'm an IP FS node right when you
push that video to ipfs they not
everybody stores a copy of that video
one person will store a copy that video
will be split up into several parts and
replicated across the network so then
you might be thinking well what if
someone deletes their node well there's
already replications everywhere
how are these nodes incentivized well
there's this idea a file coin where
these nodes are paid to store this data
so it's how to incentivize these notes
so that's kind of our complete list of
solutions for this web 3.0 we can have a
data store called ipfs we can have
etherium to store code and application
level constructs and Oracle's to pull
data from the web this is this is how
web 3.0 works this is the new stack so
this is how it works right cerium
references content big data that's
stored on ipfs it gets that static
content the distributed application gets
that content from ipfs and it gets the
global state or a theorem it's it's a
global state machine so if we combine
ipfs and aetherium we can build these
distributed decentralized applications
right but what's a talk what is what is
really a talk without talking about deep
learning rights deep learning is where
it's at we've got this thing called a
neuron in our break their cells billions
of these cells in our brain and they
make us intelligent they give us
consciousness and love and emotion all
these things we feel it because of this
thing it's a collection of them I don't
know how they work neither do you either
there's nobody neither there's the most
renowned neuroscientist in the world no
one knows how this thing works but in
the 50s some guy was like I mean I get
the basic idea there's some data that's
being fed into this thing something's
happening here and then it sends it out
and then very roughly very very roughly
he created a mathematical model for this
thing he says
he said we have these inputs let me just
take this these inputs these are a set
of numbers let me apply some kind of
summation to this and then some kind of
non-linearity as in let me take this
data and make sure that it it can learn
a function that can learn any type of
function both the linear and a nonlinear
function that means any type of function
and then output a result right so take
some data it does something to it and
then it outputs that data and what
happens here has been the topic of
debate amongst many researchers like
what do we do to it but the idea is the
same as when we take some input data
apply some kind of function to it and
then we have an output and then we chain
these things together so we got we have
a lot of them and what happened is the D
pointing revolution right all of these
things that humans are good at image
recognition driving cars etc all these
things for some reason this model that
resembles the human brain works well
sometimes even better than we do so this
is kind of this is mind boggling right
on silicon these chips we roughly
estimated the rules that are happening
here and it's doing something that even
humans can't even do could there be some
universal law of intelligence out there
that we're just slowly approximating
that we're just slowly coming close to
probably and this is our first step
there deep learning incredible
technologies okay so how do we combine
all three of these things how do we
combine ipfs aetherium and d part well
there's one really great example that I
know of called open mind that a friend
of mine has built with his community but
the idea is this if I'm a data scientist
and you have some data if I want to
train my deep learning model on your
data how do I do that in a way that
involves no third party or you don't
have to trust me that I'm gonna look at
your data say it's very sensitive like
patient data like for hospital records
how do I train my model to learn from
your data so I can make predictions
about say cancer or some other disease
without looking at your personal
information so this is a perfect example
of how you can put these three
technologies together you can have ipfs
store that data you can have aetherium
build an application level construct for
smart contracts
so that the data it doesn't have to be
stored on a central server and you could
use deep learning to learn from that
data so if you want to know how all
three of these can work together look up
open minds the website is open mind work
but it's a great example of how to
combine all these three these three
things together so where does this lead
us eventually this isn't this is a graph
of emergent higher level complexity
simple AI agents that are ants but
complex swarm behavior emerges right now
we have AI and they live on servers they
live in our phones they live on laptops
but if we could free these ai's from the
confines of servers and live and let
them live in a decentralized space they
could speak to each other they could
learn from each other and perhaps the
real solution to higher level
intelligence is to let that complexity
emerge rather than trying to code it in
why don't we just let it emerge right we
don't know how consciousness works but
we have this basic rough idea of how it
works what if we just have needs to give
it enough complexity and let that real
intelligence emerge we just can't even
understand it that is very likely the
case and if we use blob chains and we
use a theory I'm only use ipfs and all
these decentralized technologies we can
create real artificial intelligences
that are as smart if not a hundred
thousand times smarter than all of us
lastly you might be thinking why would
we want to do that why do I care about
that rising water crisis ease the spread
of infectious diseases weapons of mass
destruction North Korea Donald Trump
interstate conflict failure of climate
change adaption energy price shock
fiscal crisis ease unemployment
biodiversity loss and ecosystem collapse
some would say it's too late for us to
solve climate change it's too late no
matter what we do we're not going to
solve it we are we are headed for
destruction we are headed for oblivion
there is nothing we can do we're screwed
I don't think so because those people
don't know about the power of AI right
if we solve al
let's just say we solve it we create an
intelligence that's a smart if not
smarter than all of us we can give it an
objectives a goal a function and that
objective could be solve climate change
it would look at data in a way no human
ever could in a way that 10,000 plus
scientists put together in a room for a
hundred years couldn't solve it could
solve all these things immediately it
could move us towards this utopia that
we didn't think even possible before if
we do it the right way and if all of us
together are thinking about ways to do
this we all have to be thinking about
how these technologies work together if
you even barely understand how this
technology works it is your
responsibility to do something about it
because there are millions of people
across the world who don't even have
food in water right sufficient these in
Maslow's hierarchy of needs they don't
have any of these things how can they
come to these kinds of insights they
can't everybody in this room it's your
responsibility to do to work on this to
help make this happen how do you do that
you learn from the internet you use this
new you know university that we have is
collective University to teach yourself
to educate yourself on how these
technologies work and how you can best
influence the problems in our world
using these technologies so I want to
leave you with a single remark solve AI
or die trying that's my motto that's
what I live by and if you want to learn
more as my youtube channel subscribe
thank you very much
[Applause]